c'est la toute première biographie
d'Elisabeth borne une enquête très
fouillée une enquête sensible aussi sur
une femme aussi secrète qu'exigence pour
qui les blessures de l'enfance sont
encore à vif on en parle toutes les deux
après l'invitation signée ce soir Hélène
Bonduelle regardez
si on vous invite Bérengère bon c'est
parce que d'Elizabeth borne qui fait
aujourd'hui même son premier
anniversaire à Matignon on ne sait
finalement que peu de choses une
première ministre austère exigeante
besogneuse finalement qui se cache
derrière ce personnage vous avez enquêté
pendant un an sur cette polytechnicienne
plus techno que politique sur celle que
vous appelez la secrète
Bérengère Bonte journaliste réalisatrice
auteur ce n'est pas la première fois que
vous écrivez sur les locataires de
l'Élysée ou Matignon la secrète donc
tient sans doute cette retenue de son
histoire familiale tragique qu'elle a
tue pendant des décennies
un père juif déporté à Auschwitz qui se
suicident quand elle n'a que 11 ans
c'est finalement pendant son discours de
politique générale la gorge serrée et
reprenant son souffle qu'elle se lance
si je suis ici devant vous
première ministre de la France je le
dois à la République
c'est elle qui m'a tendu la main en me
faisant pupille de la nation alors que
j'étais cet enfant dont le père n'était
jamais vraiment revenu des camps
un CV à faire pâlir d'envie première
femme préfète de Poitou-Charentes
présidente de la RATP 3 fois ministre
avant de décrocher Matignon et le record
de longévité pour une femme pour en
arriver là vous décrivez une
personnalité exigeante avec elle-même
mais avec les autres aussi
la secrète inflige une pression
déraisonnable à son entourage borne
engueule tout le monde les directeurs et
sous-directeurs autant que les jeunes
chefs de bureau de 35 ans qui arrivent
aux réunions de cabinets transi de
trouilles mais c'est un autre chapitre
de votre livre qui est rythme la
couverture au point de vous assigner en
justice et d'en demander leur retrait la
chef du gouvernement vous reproche
d'yvoquer son orientation sexuelle et sa
vie privée mais vous assumez observez à
toutes ces époques professionnelles
depuis son divorce le mystère de cette
femme qui n'a pas de vie en dehors du
boulot alimente forcément le trouble
enfin vous décrivez une femme
intelligente rapide bugnace et l'on
connaît la tentation qui touche tous les
premiers ministres alors nous avons une
question Bérengère Bonte la secrète qui
ne lâche rien a-t-elle un autre secret
celui peut-être de se voir un jour à
l'Élysée
réponse Bérangère Bonte je l'ai posé à
beaucoup de gens je l'évoque dans le
dernier chapitre
c'est pas quelqu'un qui est en train de
construire une officine et de préparer
quelque chose pour ça en revanche c'est
une question qui l'inquiète beaucoup qui
m'a valu moi des coups de fil un peu sur
le tard de Matignon présidentielles
qu'on puisse penser que effectivement
depuis toute petite elle a certaines de
ses amis qui lui disent prochaine étape
c'est l'Élysée des politiques qui me
l'ont dit c'est à dire on sait qu'une
présidentielle c'est ce jour où on dit
toujours la rencontre d'une personne à
un moment avec le peuple etc les
circonstances peuvent faire que encore
une fois elle n'est pas en train de se
préparer mais de même qu'elle soit
disant n'avait pas fait campagne pour
Matignon ce qui est faux là évidemment
que c'est forcément on y pense forcément
et
qu'à d'autres en rêvent à sa place c'est
une enquête extrêmement fouillée je le
disais vous avez rencontré deux fois
Elisabeth borne longuement vous avez vu
tous ses proches et notamment sa sœur
Anne-Marie en quête qui permet d'abord
de comprendre le traumatisme de
l'enfance se perd qui n'est donc jamais
revenu des camps et qui va se
défenestrer parce qu'il est revenu mais
jamais totalement vous avez raison
préciser et qui va se suicider dans la
maison de famille même si la famille
hésite encore sur la version maison de
livaro en Normandie alors que Elisabeth
borne n'a que 11 ans parlez-nous de
Joseph Bornstein devenu Joseph borne à
sa sortie d'Auschwitz c'est un homme qui
qui rentre des camps qui étaient qui
étaient résistants qui a un parcours de
résistant assez assez admirable comme
beaucoup de résistants évidemment c'est
presque une banalité de dire ça mais qui
d'ailleurs s'engage dans les réseaux de
résistance
sans trop le dire à son père qui qui
lui-même est à Patrick qui est venu se
réfugier en France avec ses quatre fils
juste après le décès de sa femme et ils
étaient eux en Belgique à ce moment-là
et qui est arrêté une fois qui est
arrêté une deuxième fois qui s'échappe
et qui survit à Auschwitz avec son frère
ils sont partis ils ont été ils ont été
déportés à qui me sont revenus qu'à deux
lui et son frère voilà on le voit là
et et il sera finalement à partir du de
la naissance d'Elisabeth borne c'est une
dépression qui va l'amener
progressivement jusqu'à cette issue
fatale et c'est une enfant qui est
évidemment marquée par ce père qui avec
des avec des barreaux aux fenêtres avec
quelques moments de relation mais elle
dit elle-même que son père avait une
relation très forte avec sa sœur et elle
m'a dit mais j'aimais du réécouter
quatre fois le dictaphone et je crois
que ça lui suffisait il y a voilà alors
quand c'est un père qui a commencé à la
sortie des camps à parler à témoigner
comme beaucoup d'autres survivants et
qu'on a fait terre ça c'est aussi une
des éléments assez surprenants parce que
beaucoup de déportés n'ont pas n'ont pas
raconté lui il a tout de suite beaucoup
parlé sauf que le curé du village deux
lettres avaient été publiées où il
racontait les les chambres à gaz
l'horreur l'horreur de ses et le curé du
village a dit mais vous n’importe quoi
comment pouvez-vous inventer ça et de ce
jour-là c'est mieux Ray dans le silence
c'est sa mère Marguerite qui va d'une
manière particulière être un peu
porteuse de cette histoire alors qu'elle
n'est pas juive non elle catholique et
elle va beaucoup d'ailleurs travailler
et jusqu'aux ces derniers jours elle est
décédée à 95 ans donc voilà elle a
beaucoup travaillé sur le rapprochement
des deux des deux cultures et des deux
religions notamment sur la fin de sa vie
où elle va elle va apprendre
l'hébreu c'est ça pour pour pouvoir
traduire les textes elles-mêmes et
travailler effectivement
enfin c'est quelque chose qui a été très
très fort chez elle et qui était la
suite logique une forme d'hommage
évidemment
à son mari décédé depuis déjà longtemps
et aujourd'hui sa soeur donc l'aînée
Anne-Marie reçoit des informations de
partout sur cette histoire familiale où
elle arrivait l'arrivée d'Elizabeth
borne à Matignon a évidemment
amené pas mal de témoignages de
recherche parfois il y a eu très très
donc très intéressant du Dauphiné Libéré
de nos confrères qui sont allés chercher
dans les archives départementales les
conditions de l'arrestation de la
famille bornes avec un logeur qui qui
les a dénoncé
qui a dit je crois bien que c'est bornes
ne sont pas tout à fait non pas tout à
fait ce nom là et c'est un prêtre non
pour cacher des Israélites enfin tout
ces termes abominables et oui c'est une
histoire très très lourde quelle porte
qui est qui est évidemment douloureuse
dont elle a pas réussi à parler pendant
très très longtemps et je raconte à quel
point c'est très étonnant il y a une
journaliste du Nord qui est venue la
voir ils ont fait deux fois un portrait
depuis son entrée la matinée ils sont
fascinés par cette histoire les
Américains et la journaliste du Newton
je lui ai dit mais aux États-Unis vous
auriez fait votre carrière politique
là-dessus et elle moi m'a dit
qu'elle ne veut pas où elle ne peut pas
c'est les deux les deux ça reste très
douloureux et mais elle avait aussi
visiblement la crainte qu'on ne lui
reproche d'utiliser ça alors elle dit
très pudiquement que son environnement
était un peu lourd jusqu'à fuir quand
même l'appartement familial à 16 ans oui
c'est une femme libre qui s'est
émancipée comme elle m'a dit c'est assez
étonnant je vers 16 ans à cette époque
là c'est quand même pas non plus
on est à la fin des années 70 pas si
fréquent mais elle trouve ça elle voit
pas eu le problème en l'occurrence elle
s'en va avec celui qui deviendra le père
de son fils donc oui rien n'est j'ai
sauvé aussi grâce aux mathématiques
alors
elle a une conscience assez claire de ce
qui s'est passé en tout cas puis
progressivement
du suicide au moment où vraiment elle se
retrouve toute seule le monde s'écroule
et elle se dit il y a qui tient dans la
vie c'est des maths les maths c'est un
ou 0 et donc elle s'est effectivement
enfermée là dedans
un peu coupé de ses émotions il faut
bien le dire je veux dire tous les
témoignages des différentes époques de
sa vie toutes les époques
professionnelles
rapportent ça d'une façon ou d'une autre
alors polytechnicienne en 1980 elle
devient ingénieur des Ponts elle
commence une carrière politique d'abord
comme au fonctionnaire puis elle devient
conseillère équipement éducation Jack
Lang Lionel Jospin préfet en poids
touche Charente elle devient pas trop de
la SNCF puis de la RATP c'est une femme
de gauche quelles sont ses convictions
alors moi j'ai toujours du mal à dire de
gauche je aimeriez draguer me dit même
bien sûr que non on l'a jamais été de
gauche Aurélien Rousseau son directeur
de cabinet me dit mais si mais dans les
premiers nos premiers échanges sur le
travail sur la valeur du travail j'ai vu
la femme de gauche moi je pense j'irais
pas quelqu'un qui a une charpente
politique et une culture politique elle
a pas d'ivronnée aux biographies de
Bloom et de Mendès France de Jean
Lacouture c'est on n'est pas là-dedans
en revanche qui a un fond de valeur
49-3 elle a un sens politique vraiment
elle a elle a elle a un sens politique
au sens par exemple la période de de
Poitou-Charentes elle se retrouve elle
se retrouve très faite franchement
alors qu'elle avait fait des cabinets à
la mairie de Paris à l'urbanisme chez
les nageuses peints à Matignon vous vous
retrouvez préfet vous devez quand même
sacrément faire en sorte que tous ces
gens se parlent elles elles tord le bras
de ses golden Royal qui est présidente
de région pour lui faire mettre la main
au pot sur un projet de Jean-Pierre
Raffarin qui sont ennemi juré enfin elle
sait arriver à ses fins politiques c'est
une terreur ça on l'a compris avec ses
collaborateurs absolument aussi j'aurais
qu'on en vienne à la signation en
justice et ses chapitres dans Isabelle
borne demande le retrait des chapitres
entiers sont des passages parfois sur
des choses totalement anodines mais mais
effectivement pour le coup ça pour le
coup c'est quand même une vraie surprise
et une source d'inquiétude faut le dire
franchement qu'une première ministre en
exercice tout d'un coup demande
effectivement à voilà j'espère que la
justice nous rappellera que on a le
droit d'enquêter et d'écrire vous
précisiez pour être les spectateurs vous
vous assumez d'avoir évoqué ces rumeurs
concernant son orientation sexuelle mais
moi je pars de d'éléments qu'elle a soit
elle-même mis sur la table soit c'est
très proche c'est ou soit d'éléments qui
étaient dans le débat les rumeurs
d'homosexualité ne vient pas de moi elle
dément en arrivant
[Musique]
dans têtu qui est quand même donc le
magazine très identifié par la
communauté LGBT donc c'est un sujet qui
est sur la table elle dit elle dément
voilà et elle ajoute mais j'ai un
compagnon qu'est-ce que vous faites vous
faites la bio vous cherchez qui est
cette personne s'il avait eu un profil
totalement entre guillemets anodin s'il
avait été prof de sport
ou boucher charcutier et j'adore la
viande
l'histoire était terminée sauf qu'il a
un profil très politique qui pose
énormément de questions qu'il est il a
été candidat aux européennes il est très
engag il est toujours enfin il a été
président d'une association qui appelait
à la manif pour tous
jusqu'à cette île jusqu'à cet hiver elle
l'a embauché à la RATP quand elle était
présidente autant de questions que j'ai
voulu lui poser une fois que j'ai
vraiment eu la certitude sur cette photo
sur tout qui a été publié par closer
voilà et il se trouve que à la fin de la
fin de la fin de la fin je découvre
qu'en fait
depuis deux ans il est passé avec une
autre femme il le dit lui-même sur son
blog donc en fait
elle elle la seule certitude que j'ai
finalement c'est que cet homme n'est pas
son compagnon pourquoi pourquoi met-elle
ça sur la table ça posait vrai question
je veux dire honnêtement c'est voilà ça
s'appelle un mensonge d'ailleurs selon
vos sources l'Élysée aurait même trouvé
épatante l'idée qu'une première ministre
fasse son coming out c'est son
anniversaire à Matignon aujourd'hui je
vais vous montrer un tout petit extrait
voilà comment on lui a fêté sur les
bancs de l'hémicycle côté insoumis
en l'espace d'un an vous avez fait de
notre pays une poudrière bravo Madame la
première ministre quel anniversaire le
programme que nous mettons en oeuvre
madame la Présidente panneau c'est celui
sur lequel le président de la République
a été élu et définitivement vous ne
mettez pas mais ce n'est pas Jean-Luc
Mélenchon mais Emmanuel Macron que les
Français ont choisi et on a pas marre de
la dureté du job elle s'accroche
jusqu'au bout elle veut rester moi je
crois qu'elle va rester je pense que je
vois pas pourquoi elle a pas démérités
je pense que personne d'autre te
trouvera de majorité en l'état donc je
faut qu'on m'explique quel est l'intérêt
et elle dans le contenu de tout ce que
je raconte de toute de sa pugnacité de
la façon dont elle s'accroche dont elle
s'est accrochée dans la période où elle
était directrice de cabinet de Ségolène
Royal notamment sous les yeux d'un
ministre de l'économie qui s'appelait
Emmanuel Macron qui a bien vu à quel
point elle était du roman et capable de
résister oui pour toutes ces raisons je
pense après les circonstances font
peut-être qu'elle finir
merci beaucoup Bérengère Bérengère Bond
qui signe donc la secrète la première
biographie aux éditions de l'archipel
c'est une enquête fouillée passionnante
sur une femme politique à la trajectoire
incroyable il faut le